how can light have momentum if it
doesn't have mass momentum does not
require mass this episode was made
possible by generous supporters on
patreon
hey crazies I get these comments all the
time and I'm tired of responding
individually I'm making a video instead
okay so momentum the first time students
see it it's written like this the V
stands for velocity and the M stands for
mass the P is short for a latin word
meaning to go to or seek it's a nice
simple relationship you can have more
momentum by moving faster or by having
more mass but momentum isn't really
relevant unless there are at least two
objects it only matters for these cars
if they run into each other that's
something you might call a collision for
obvious reasons we even categorize them
based on how much kinetic energy is
retained during the collision
unfortunately this gives students all
sorts of wrong impressions misconception
number one these so-called collisions
don't require physical contact all that
matters is that the objects exchange
forces sure this collision involved
physical contact but there are many
forces in this universe and not all of
them require physical contact
like Newtonian gravity for example
orbits are a kind of continuous
collision you can model this motion
using momentum exchanges and it works
besides if you want to get super
technical there's no such thing as
physical contact at least in the way
most people understand it all contact
forces are just complex manifestations
of the electromagnetic force are you
pushing on something that's just
electric repulsion between atoms on the
outside of two solids pulling on
something that's just electric
attraction between molecules in a solid
buoyant force that's electric propulsion
again but in fluids instead of solids
friction actually we're still trying to
work out some details on that one
my point is that the word collision is a
very misleading word their interactions
not collisions misconception number two
momentum does not require mass this
equation is not a fundamental definition
it's a special case for slow-moving
objects with rest mass it's pretty good
for speeds less than about 10% the speed
of light any faster than that and you'll
need the version from special relativity
this gamma factor adjusts it so it's
more accurate even then it still only
works for objects with rest mass
surprise light doesn't have any of that
so even this equation fails for light
that doesn't mean light has rest mass it
means the equation sucks the one for
light looks like this but hold on a
second if we really want to understand
how light can have momentum we need to
answer a better question what the heck
is momentum that's the one when these
cars run into each other they each exert
a force on the other with Newton's
second law we could plug in a mass and
get an acceleration that changes the
speeds of each car for as long as that
force is exerted which is mainly just
during the collision so can light exert
forces on things oh yes it most
definitely can although not nearly as
much as an object with rest mass there
is a force on each side of this piece of
paper from the light in this room it's
just on the order of nano Newtons if
you've got a really big reflector though
like a solar sail the force can add up
the light hits the back of the sail and
pushes it forward if we use Newton's
second law
wait a minute light doesn't have rest
mass this isn't gonna work if I'm being
completely honest though that isn't even
Newton's second law sure this is the
first version students ever see but it's
not actually about mass in accelerations
this is the real Newton's second law any
change in momentum for a single object
tells us the force experienced by that
object so you can think of momentum as
the earth something as light hits the
sail and reflects the change in momentum
results in a force light can exert
forces therefore light has momentum no
mass required anyway what was the third
thing I think it was velocity yeah yeah
that was it misconception number three
momentum doesn't
require velocity light is just an
electromagnetic wave
so if light has momentum then it stands
to reason the electromagnetic field does
- hmm remember that weird pointing
vector it described the flow of energy
in the electromagnetic field well we've
already seen that momentum is related to
energy for light which means this energy
flow vector should also give us a
momentum that doesn't even require the
fields to be changing say we've got two
big metal plates above and below
carrying some charge that gives us an
electric field now let's say we've got
two strong magnetic poles on either side
that gives us a magnetic field the
pointing vector tells us that as long as
we've got both fields we've got an
energy flow and so we've got a momentum
that momentum points into your screen in
this example there's no moving matter
here and the fields are static yet there
is a momentum and that momentum must be
accounted for at least if we expect
conservation of momentum to hold true so
how could light have momentum if it
doesn't have mass momentum does not
require mass it doesn't even require
velocity this equation is not a
fundamental definition for fast-moving
objects it's this for light it's this
all that really matters is that a change
in momentum results in a force light can
exert a force therefore light has
momentum
end of story if you've got any other
questions about momentum please ask in
the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us click that notification bell if
you're really into what we do here and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy the featured comment
comes from our John Marco who asked can
we generate electricity if we pass light
through a coil well yeah that's how
we're receiving antenna works long
straight conductors for the electric
field and a circular coil for the
magnetic field it just isn't enough
current to do much other than receive a
signal anyway thanks for watching